[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro de dimanche aux
politiques vitrines brisées gaz
lacrymogènes mouvement de foule
c'est l'ambiance qui règne depuis
bientôt six mois le samedi après midi
dans les centres villes en france à
dijon la mobilisation a été forte et les
conséquences sur le commerce sont réels
presque tous les commerçants annoncent
enregistré une baisse de chiffre
d'affaires les salles dit que certains
évaluent à 40% tandis que d'autres
pronostics de prochaine fermeture alors
les manifestants les gilet jaune mais
aussi ce qu'il faut bien appeler des
casseurs ont ils eu raison du commerce
de centre ville les commerçants ou
peuvent-ils s'en sortir ou du moins
compenser leurs pertes faut-il un
véritable plan daide pour les boutiques
on en débat ce dimanche matin avec mes
invités denis favier bonjour bonjour
vous êtes le président de chopines dijon
la fédération des commerçants dijonnais
nathalie koenders bonjour je vous êtes
premier adjoint au maire de dijon
arnaud guven à tam bonjour vous êtes
membre de la france insoumise et vous
avez participé à plusieurs
manifestations ces dernières semaines
à dijon merci à tous d'avoir accepté
cette invitation est vous qui nous
regarde et vous pouvez bien sûr
commenter cette émission sur les réseaux
sociaux avec le hashtag dit mme paul
bourgogne alors avant de vous donner la
parole ici autour de cette table je vous
propose de donner la parole aux
commerçants ils sont les premiers
concernés par cette situation qu'on va
aborder durant toute cette émission on
en a rencontré dans les rues de dijon je
vous propose d'écouter leurs difficultés
on a été à moins 30% de chiffre sur le
mois de décembre
et puis depuis deux 2 janvier à avril
j'ai pas encore d'impact pour mais on
est entre -25 et -12% tous les mois
parce qu'on va ouvrir le samedi entre
19h30 et 21h en fonction de la violence
de la manifestation fonction du moment
où où le cortège est vraiment dit
stocking ne peut pas accueillir nos
clients tant que ça se bat devant tant
qu'il ya du gaz lacrymo qui sature
l'atmosphère ici on
les yeux qui piquent c'est pas étanche
comme bâtiment mais au fil des mois on
s'aperçoit par le dire de nos clients
aussi de ceux qui viennent en tout cas
moi qui désertent le centre ville le
samedi après midi
même s'ils ont conscience qu'ils n'ont
pas pas un risque sur leur propre
personne mais c'est vrai que dans notre
domaine de l'enfant né des enfants
milieu des gaz lacrymogènes et cris et
des bruits c'est pas mais je comprends
pour une main membres qu'ils assuraient
que c'est enfin ce n'est pas forcément
quelque chose d'agréable quoi voilà on
vient d'entendre la position des
commerçants du centre-ville de dijon
leur président est là et on lui donnera
la parole dans un instant mais j'ai
envie de donner la parole aux
manifestants j'ai envie de dire arnaud
granata vous entendez les difficultés
des commerçants qu'est-ce que vous
comment vous avez vécu ces samedi de
mobilisation
oui je comprends tout à fait les
difficultés des commerçants mais il faut
voir aussi que après 25 semaines de
manifestations consécutives c'est un
mouvement qui historique en france ce
don de dire qu' il ya des causes et des
conséquences je comprends que d'ailleurs
les commerçants critique pas à l'ailé
les raisons de la des manifestations il
change souvent très ouvert sur la
question mais ils disent nous on n'en
peut plus quoi c'est tout à fait
compréhensible d'ailleurs je vais au
début les missions vous avez bien fait
la distinction entre les gilet jaune qui
ont des revendications totalement
légitime et éventuellement des casseurs
qui presserait même si dans le croissant
est on est quand même assez épargné il
ya eu la cage peut-être que peut-être
que nathalie koenders pour nous parler
du mobilier urbain par moments mais ce
que je veux dire c'est qu'il ya les deux
phénomènes
ils sont côte à côte il ya d'une part
les manifestants qui toutes façons créer
une ambiance le samedi dans les rues de
dijon et les affrontements avec la
police n'arrange rien et puis il ya
aussi les casseurs ça ce sont les
débordements c'est une autre question
mais les deux créent une ambiance
forcément graphisme il faut aussi quand
même pointé la responsabilité du
gouvernement qui joue le pourrissement
depuis quand même maintenant six mois
moi je participe quand même aux
manifestations et je vois aussi que du
côté des forces de l'ordre il peut y
avoir des phénomènes de provocation
aujourd'hui il y en a aussi du côté des
manifestants le jeu des douanes pas du
tout le fait
il peut y avoir aussi des provocations
d'un côté comme de l'autre mais
l'absence de réponse du gouvernement sur
les thématiques de pouvoir d'achat à
diesse f
deryck les revendications qui sont
portées finalement depuis depuis de
nombreuses semaines mois mais aussi je
pense aussi à françois rebsamen qui dit
d'un ton martial les manifestations ça
suffit je pense que c'est pas de nature
malheureusement apaisé apaiser le débat
qui doit y avoir et malheureusement
voilà je pense les manifestations sont
amenés à continuer nathalie koenders
vous du côté de la mairie comment vous
avez vécu ces choses là vous pouvez bien
sûr répondre sur le ton martial du maire
françois rebsamen 25 semaines que le
centre ville de dijon est bloqué donc
les conséquences commencent à être très
lourdes pour la ville de dijon pour les
dijonnais parce que je rappelle que
pendant les samedis après midi il ya
plus de transports en commun il ya plus
de tramway les conséquences sont
également très lourdes pour les
commerçants et artisans mais je
laisserai parler leurs représentants
pour la ville aussi ce qui veut dire
qu'en fait tu sois là où les séquelles
moi enfin au bout du compte
effectivement mais je pense les
conséquences sont lourdes également pour
les gilet jaune parce que je fais aussi
la distinction entre les casseurs et les
gilet jaune est aujourd'hui le message
qui était compréhensible au début il est
complètement inaudible parce que les
gens en ont marre sont exaspérés et moi
je pense qu'effectivement ça doit cesser
ou alors sous une autre forme
parce qu'on sait que le samedi c'est un
moment fort pour les commerçants où ils
font le maximum de leur chiffre
d'affaires
et là je pense qu'à un moment il va
falloir que les manifestants en prennent
conscience et moi je suis le manifester
est un droit mais la liberté circuit des
au centre-ville l'est également
et aujourd'hui avec le même adressé non
pas le seul habilité intéressant on dire
que votre message finalement n'est plus
très audible message que j ai je n'ai
plus très haut dit parce que les
français aient bien s'il soutenait
beaucoup le mouvement au départ
commencent en avoir un peu marre de ne
pas pouvoir faire leurs courses le
samedi quoi parce que c'est souvent le
seul jour pour les gens qui travaillent
toute la semaine et ça j'imagine que
vous l'entendez aussi imaginer encore
50% de la population française qui
soutiennent ce mouvement légitime après
six mois de six mois de manifestations
je pense que c'est quelque chose tu as
quand même le chiffre baisse mais il ya
quand même un soutien qui réel dans la
population ce que ça fait écho à des
revendications qui sont qui viennent pas
nulle part je veux dire l'élection
présidentielle a rien réglé
malheureusement il y avait déjà des
thématiques des problématiques chez les
commerçants avant le centre d'auch
une par exemple qui subit de la
désertification dans son centre ça date
pas de gilet jaune
on va y venir peut-être oui je veux dire
c'est que c'est que des articles
moi je regarde un peu la presse et des
articles sur la désertification des
centres-villes sa date d'avant d'avant
les gilet jaune
il ya aussi un problème moi je vous
laisserai à perdre tout à l'heure et moi
j'aurai plein de propositions à vous
faire sur sur le plan de sauvetage des
commerces de centre-ville mais pas que
parce que je pense qu'il ya aussi un tel
problème qui n'est pas que deux lors que
des conséquences des jeunes qui eux sont
une cause les jaunes sont ils consistent
pas des conséquences
on va y venir arnaud granata mais
d'abord on est sur ce plan là ça veut
pas dire qu'il n'y a pas d'autre
problème c'est les commerçants et dans
le centre-ville de dijon et j'imagine
qu'on y est on y viendra denis favier
comment vous avez vécu les choses et
qu'est ce que vous répondez quand on
vous dit ça je réponds simplement que là
à l'heure actuelle on a trois cent
cinquante pour cent d'augmentation du
nombre des liquidations judiciaires pour
le centre ville de dijon et qui est
plutôt analyser par une d'une
conséquence de la minute des
manifestations est allé tous les samedis
des gilet jaune je suis désolé d'en
arriver là
oui 350% sadi pas vraiment les choses
denis favier il ya m en 20 à 30 dossiers
alors déposants et suit précisément et
ça fait à peu près 300 et 900 promet le
parcours habituel de l'année précédente
alors effectivement on ne peut pas tout
mettre sur le dos des gilet jaune
effectivement mai 2007 déjà très
difficile il faut pas dire que c'était
forcément très difficile oui pour
certains effectivement pas forcément de
bons emplacements personnellement la
bonne lors des manifestations de nous
aviez c'est ce qui peut être étaient
plus fragiles que d'autres aussi et donc
qu'ils subissent de plein fouet les
manifestations ciel c'est logique mais
c'est un problème de trésorerie etc
mais malheureusement quand vous avez une
baisse de chiffre d'affaires qui est
vraiment
la conséquence des manifestations dès
début décembre
et malheureusement prolonger jusqu'à
aujourd'hui malheureusement je ne peut
imputer sakho gilet jaune écho aux
manifestations répétées
alors effectivement il faut modérer en
disant que nous sommes le croissant
ouest c'est ce que je dis régulièrement
par rapport au croissant ouest nous
n'avons pas de vitrine descendu à
déplorer effectivement ça se concentrent
davantage du côté de la rue de la
préfecture où il ya plus loin le
commerce - de commerce mais plus
effectivement de de dégâts et puis des
débats au niveau bien entendu des
infrastructures de la ville mais
effectivement on n'a pas à déplorer ça
mais c'est un climat anxiogène que nous
avons depuis le 17 nov commerçants au
delà de la casse c'est que les gens
n'ont plus envie d'aller faire du
shopping en centre-ville parce que tout
simplement l'ambiance n'est pas quoi
exactement
les manifestations des manifestants
pardon ne sont pas forcément agressif
mais quand vous avez ce que l'on peut
voir sur les écrans ici un certain
nombre de personnes qui prennent toute
la largeur de la rue quand vous avez des
gens qui sont dans les commerces à y
rentrer et où on sait effectivement il
ya une certaine appréhension
et puis il faut dire que la baisse de
chiffre d'affaires est aussi la
conséquence du fait que nous sommes une
métropole et que nous attirons du monde
du grand extérieur et que ce monde là ne
peut venir que le samedi et sachant
qu'il ya des manifestants et des
manifestations donc le samedi à dijon
ces gens là nous les voyons alors vous
avez des difficultés mais est ce que
vous comprenez par là même les
revendications des manipulations escales
des commerçants qui sont juste des
jaunes est ce que ça pourrait arriver ça
je dirais pas qu'ils aient des
commerçants à force
au début je dis pourquoi pas il y en
avait qui les a protégés étaient les
premiers à comprendre certaines
revendications et c'est parce que ce
sont aussi les gens qui consomment dans
vos commerces qui ont difficilement
pouvoir d'achat donc ça ne peut pas vous
laisser insensible non mais ça c'est
évident mais au bout de 26 samedi
malheureusement l'état d'esprit des
commerçants on n'est plus du tout du
tout le même non plus je pense que tout
le monde a envie d'arrêter de manifester
dès samedi
mais alors est-ce qu'on peut se mettre
d'accord aujourd'hui sur france 3 est ce
que est ce qu'on peut se dire qu'il ya
peut-être d'autres modes d'action
enclenché est ce que vous vous dites à
vos amis qui manifestent il ya peut-être
d'autres choses à faire que de
manifester le samedi en son entrejeu
peuple
je ne prendre une forme de manifestation
ou une autre mais comment les battre oui
je peux oui je peux vous quel est votre
point de vue moi mon point de vue c'est
que ce que j'analyse c'est que il ya un
problème social et donc il faut des
rayons dès l'accord gouvernemental
les commerçants ont des problèmes
financiers moi je pense au fait que se
projeter sur l'avenir quand on a des
gros problèmes de trésorerie c'est
extrêmement compliqué on a très peu de
confiance sur l'avenir
les clients viennent - une baisse de
pouvoir d'achat donc tout ce qu'on
propose à la france a soumis ce qu'on a
proposé la présidentielle est ce qu on
compte une proposée sur l'augmentation
des salaires minimums mais je sais que
ça peut poser des preuves de trésorerie
pour les entreprises qui vont devoir
assumer le choc de l'augmentation des
salaires et c'est pour cette raison
qu'ils allaient mettre un exactement 1
une sorte de fonds de péréquation de
fonds solidarité inter entreprises ou
les grandes entreprises qui ne paient
pas le même taux d'imposition que les
petites contribue au fait de soulager
les contributions sociales des ans que
j'entends je vous coupe parce que
évidemment ce n'était pas ma question
puisque ça là on est dans le cadre d
éventuellement des annonces de manuel
macron qui vous convienne ou pas moi jsk
d'autres modes d'action et coûteux que
de manifester en centre ville le samedi
est ce qu'on peut imaginer autre chose
c'est un droit mais il ya aussi la
reprise de hong kong le dimanche je
m'attaque alors que le problème
aujourd'hui et peut-être que les
déclarations du président de la
république et je le pense aussi n'ont
pas été à la hauteur des attentes
notamment en termes de justice sociale
de justice fiscale et c'est maintenant
le samedi après midi comme on élit dit
plus de 26 samedi
il ya un vrai problème de vivre ensemble
à dijon comme je les dis je suis le
droit de manifester est un droit mais
aujourd'hui est bien de nombreux
dijonnais ne peuvent plus prendre le
tramway ne peuvent plus circuler
librement centre ville et là c'est un
vrai problème de vivre ensemble la peine
est juste en tant que citoyen le titre
privé je vais dans des commerces etc
je peux vous dire aussi qu'il ya des
gars parce qu'on voit les commerçants
mais derrière il ya aussi des salariés
de commerçants qui ont peur pour leur
emploi
ce qu'ils craignent pour leur emploi et
qui instille voilà on a écrit un moment
10 et qui comprennent les revendications
mais qui disent pourquoi pas trouver une
autre forme indique mme le dimanche
pourquoi pas parce qu'on sait que le
samedi c'est des moments importants pour
les commerçants américains c'est ce
qu'il fallait interdire ces
manifestations je sais que par moments
françois rebsamen a esquissé cette
possibilité est-ce qu'il fallait aller
jusque là est ce que vous regrettez pas
avoir peut-être demander plus clairement
au préfet d'avoir un périmètre
d'interdiction de manifestations comme
ça se fait dans certaines villes à paris
à lyon etc
alors vous faites bien de le signifier
que c'est la compétence du trafic le
maire de dijon par principe il ne les a
pas autorisés donc si elles ne sont pas
autorisés on peut penser qu'elles sont
interdites
il a pris un arrêté hier pour sur
certaines zones
maintenant je pense qu'il essaye de
trouver un équilibre pour que les gens
puissent manifester et qui est aussi un
maintien de l'ordre maintenant je tiens
aussi à saluer quand même les forces de
l'ordre qui sont à bout aussi les
policiers nationaux les policiers
municipaux qui sont pris tous les
samedis et je souhaite vraiment allé
saluer pour leur professionnalisme
et voilà est sûre sur leur action même
si et c'est pas moi qui et c'est pas à
moi d'en juger s'il ya des violences
policières et bien il ya des engagements
clairs ni à des enquêtes judiciaires et
c'est pas à moi d'en juger
arnaud granata mais est-ce que vous êtes
pas trompés de combat finalement parce
que quand on entend que ça soit madame
koenders où monsieur favier ils disent
oui on a des employés finalement qui
gagnent pas plus que les gilets jaunes
qui manifeste qui peuvent connaître des
périodes de chômage partiel est donc
finalement c'est peut-être dramatique
aussi pour ces gens là non je pense pas
qu'on se trompe de combat parce que moi
ce que je veux essayer de faire
comprendre à sur ce plateau c'est que
les intérêts des commerçants les
intérêts des salariés et des dirigeants
qui sont aussi des salariés sont des
intérêts qui sont convergents
j'ai expliqué tout à l'heure relancés
relancer l'activité par l'augmentation
des salaires on en assurant un filet de
sécurité aux petits commerçants je pense
que ça c'est une politique digne
d'intérêt général je pense que les
pompeux considéré et c'est pour ça que
même au début du mouvement des chemises
jaunes moi j'ai des amis personnels qui
sont artisans et qui son gilet jaune et
qui sont dans le temps les goûts la
biomasse envoyé mon mandat mais vous
voyez aussi d'un bon oeil les réseaux
les revendications de base
moi je pense vraiment que il doit y
avoir un dialogue qui doit s'instaurer
entre les gilet jaune et les commerçants
denis chacun prenne conscience que les
intérêts des deux choses premièrement
adopter une autre forme et pas forcément
effectivement une manifestation tous les
samedis effectivement comme dit nathalie
koenders
vous pouvez changer de jour ça peut être
le dimanche
en outre être un autre jour de semaine
comme un gilet jaune nous entende
deuxième phase qui manifeste les
deuxièmes
deuxième chose sûre que je voulais
aborder du fait d'avoir été reçu par le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
on va j -c le secrétaire d'état j'ai
deux associations de gilet jaune
côte-d'orienne qui m'ont contacté pour
organiser une table ronde
elle a été organisée avec la ville la
préfecture etc nous n'avons abouti
rien pas de possibilité dredd
possibilité il n'y a pas une discussion
possible ça a été deux heures de perdues
et je vous propose de regarder ce que ce
que font les français finalement les
habitudes de consommation comment elles
ont évolué dans un sondage réalisé
courant avril près d'un tiers des
français dit avoir changé ses habitudes
d'achat le samedi avec un taux qui
atteint même 37 % dans les grandes
agglomérations et parmi eux bien il y en
a 25 % qui ont davantage utilisé le
commerce en ligne et 17% qui ont
privilégié des villes sans manifestation
c'est donc qui a un véritable impact
dans les habitudes de consommation je
sais pas si c'est ce que cherchent les
manifestants mais en tous les cas c'est
ce qu'ils osent ont au moins réussi à
obtenir
moi j'ai jamais rencontré de
manifestants qui disent chouette on va
on va mettre les commerçants sur la
paille je pense que c'est pas du tout
l'ambiance et la philosophie des gens je
suis renvoyé les commerçants à des
plateformes dont je ne citerai pas le
nom
allez les les consommateurs à des
plateformes sur internet dont je ne
citerai pas le nom peut pas leur faire
de pub
vous imaginez pas votre philosophie
c'est bien nous pouvons quand même que
la fin de la france a soumis ces deux là
se relocaliser les activités la clé
c'est par ici sauve elle a concentré
d'actifs
moi je suis pas je suis pas un
organisateur des manifestations il ya un
mouvement social auquel vous dit pas
tout vous êtes maintenant oui bien sûr
que je participe mais le gouvernement ne
veut pas répondre joue le pourrissement
il se dit que absolument il arrivera à
bout des gens et que et qu' il passera
en force
sauf que on n'a jamais vu çà six mois de
manifestations consécutives je crois
qu'à un moment donné il faut que le
gouvernement prenne ses responsabilités
parce que c'est par leur rectitude et
leur attitude qui sont en train de
détruire des commerces et de
gouvernement qui ça c'est votre votre os
édition vocalises et vos solutions pour
pour que ça se passe mieux denis favier
vous vous avez rencontré le ministre
bruno le maire et ses secrétaires d'état
à bercy à plusieurs reprises vous
continuez à l'éleveur c'est pas mignon
on suit avec assiduité toutes ces
réunions est est ce que les choses
avancent
est ce qu'il y a aujourd'hui déjà les
choses concrètes sonnantes et
trébuchantes qui vont vous aider vous
c'est à dire vous commerçants de dijon
bien entendu ce discours national fait
effectivement la fédération shopping
dijon s'est organisée avec d'autres
fédérations au niveau national nous
avons écrit au ministre nous avons été
reçus je le précise quand même cinq
jours après nous en sommes au cinquième
rendez-vous et petit à petit nous avons
obtenu des choses des également aux
interviews quand vous sortez on vous
sent un peu circonspect
oui mais parce que forcément y'a pas
toujours dire oui immédiatement
ça rentre aussi dans des négociations
etc ce sont des appels téléphoniques
avaient obtenu des étalements vous des
étalements donc de paiement de charges
sur 20 mois
nous avons obtenu également une
exonération d'impôts à savoir impôts
directs c'est-à-dire impôt sur les
sociétés puis la cfcv qui est
renseignements la taxe professionnelle
que les commerçants payent en général en
fin d'année donc voilà c'est ce désir
est satisfait non parce que c'est pas
assez
mais ce n'est pas assez parce que ce
dont manque le commerçant à l'heure
actuelle sénat de trésorerie
oui j'ai l'aide de consommateurs et des
commerçants à dijon qui ont mis un
certain temps pour se créer une
trésorerie pour être tranquille chaque
fin de mois et avec les actions répétées
tous les samedis
cette trésorerie à neige au soleil
est-ce que du côté de la municipalité
vous êtes en attente aussi de choses qui
peuvent aider les commerçants alors
c'est pas forcément de l'argent sonnant
et trébuchant mais gardez vous que je
demande et non mais enfin il s'est déjà
fait entendre
la ville a fait ce qu'elle peut oh pas
l'avis de fait ce qu'elle peut d'abord
la ville est propre
dès la fin des manifestations la ville
et prendre vous pouvez vous balader le
dimanche matin ce que je fais moi avec
mon chien
la ville est nickel vous avez des gels
de droite terrasse en parler mieux que
moi dont on pense qu'il ya des choses
qui sont faites il ya des choses qui
sont faites en dehors c'est ce que vous
pouvez aller plus loin c'est vrai que
les collectivités territoriales elles
elles peuvent pas tout mais on fait le
maximum
déjà pas le travail de toutes les
équipes j'ai salué le travail de la
police municipale mais également les
services de propreté qui font un contre
un centre ville est bien propre et
agréable
dès la fin des manifestations on a
également été bien le maire a voté enfin
on a voté au conseil municipal sur
proposition du maire de l'exonération
des droits de terrassa concerne ceux qui
ont des terrasses des droits de voirie
etc
on a fait des week-ends aussi
stationnement gratuit on aide les unions
commerciales pour mettre en place cette
formation des relations maintenant on
également en attente puisque les maires
ont été reçus par le ministre de
l'économie et des finances qui avait
effectivement annoncé des étalements
nous on est plus pur des exonérations il
a dit oui au cas par cas
ils vont mettre aussi des fonds mais en
fait c'est des fonds fisac qui réoriente
mais voilà pour l'animation commerciale
maintenant je pense que pour faire
revenir les gens de samedi au centre
ville
il faut que ça cesse parce qu'on va pas
dire aux gens et mettre de l'argent sur
des opérations de communication au
centre ville alors que les
manifestations sont toujours s'il s'est
un peu compliqué je vous proposons est
allé rencontrer le président de la
chambre de commerce de côte d'or pour
qu'il nous dit son sentiment est aussi
les actions éventuelles que la cci peut
avoir pour aider les commerçants très
très concrètement près de chez nous
écouter c'est difficile pour eux
pourquoi tout simplement parce que quand
vous avez pendant vingt-cinq seuls 25
semaines vous avez des pertes de
chiffres d'affaires
n'oubliez pas que dans les commerçants
vous venez de l'entendre ya des
personnes qui ont tout investi 1 qui ont
vendu leur maison pour faire un commerce
quand ils peuvent pas fonctionner donc
j'allais dire d'un point de vue
professionnel perte de chiffre
d'affaires c'est énorme et d'un point de
vue personnel a effectivement certains
commerçants qui tous les samedis vienne
et tous les samedis sont obligées de
fermer leurs oeufs leur boutique à cause
des gilets jaunes un moment donné ce
sont des pertes mais les portes et on
vous l'a dit c'est entre 20 et 10 et 50
% il ya des nanas ici 50%
qu'est ce que vous proposez vous
concrètement au niveau local lan ou au
niveau local ce qu'on a proposé est ce
que ce qui est un petit pont clencher on
dit que simplement il faut clé pour
aider les commerçants qu'on leur donne
effectivement des possibilités décalage
de charge qui l'urssaf est haute mais
aussi sur monde d exemption totale de
charges dans certains domaines la
première étant nous les chambres de
commerce d'yves sur des taxes de frais
de chambre et on pourrait très bien
envisager que les taxes même si c'est
symbolique et c'est pas une somme énorme
et que symboliquement on puisse ne pas
les encaisser mais malheureusement ça ne
dépend pas de nous sa dépense du
ministère les données des finances alors
les exonérations de taxes de frais de
chambre il dit c'est symbolique mais est
ce que vous dites c'est une belle idée
oui mais effectivement c'est très peu
donc on demande davantage et c'est pour
ça que j'aurais souhaité même si même du
fait nous a accordée par le biais d'un
vote fin mars que je ne me trompe pas
alors que je les ai vus début février
des z indirecte dans d'autres régions en
france et des aides directes directement
donc des régions pour les commerçants
entre 1000 et 10000 euros d'ailleurs ce
qui permettrait de refaire lt ce qui
n'est pas le leur c'est ce que ce que
vous vous êtes favorable à ce que la
région puisse éventuellement aider plus
les commerçants concernés
d'ailleurs pas forcément cas du jour
cette émission est très dijonnaise parce
que c'est là qu'il ya eu le plus de
manifestations le plus de manifestants
il ya bien d'autres villes dans la
région qui ont au moins dans la première
partie du mouvement souffert de ces
manifestations
oui après il faut savoir qu'aussi clergé
ont comme toutes les collectivités
sont soumis elles ne peuvent pas
augmenter leurs dépenses de
fonctionnement de plus de 1,2 pour cent
donc c'est aussi une demande qu'on a
fait à l'état je pense qu'on a été
autant entendu que toutes les dépenses
liées au gilet jaune puis sept enlevés
de du contrat d' de contracter
l'histoire n'allait pas passer un coup
de fil à marie-guite dufay en sortant de
ce plateau là pour lui dire de des
commerçants non mais je sais qu'elle le
fait n'est jamais bon c'est déjà
maintenant en fonction cette possibilité
si elle peut le faire plus de par sa
compétence économique je souhaiterais
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'on a demandé au
gouvernement c'est à dire que pour un
euro versé par le gouvernement enfin par
l'état excusez moi à un fonds local qui
serait la région la région donnera
également un euro voilà c'est mettre le
pied à l'étrier à la région pour que
effectivement ça aille plus loin
ce que j'espère un autre veine à tam sur
ces aides aux commerçants ou penser que
c'est nécessaire aujourd'hui
alors là on est dans une situation où il
ya une urgence donc répondre à une
urgence moi j'y vois pas spécialement un
inconvénient mais avant de répondre
effectivement une réponse urgence mais
moi je pense qu'il ya d'abord une remise
en cause de la philosophie de politique
générale qui a à mettre en question
c'est à dire que cette situation
n'arrive pas ex nihilo
c'est le fruit d'une vingtaine d'années
de politique les grands centres
commerciaux qui peuvent je m'en sert
notamment à auxerre par exemple en
centre-ville où il ya des grosses
difficultés de fermeture de commerces du
à l'implantation de deux grosses doses
commercial
ça c'est une philosophie qu'il faut
remettre en cause de même
moi ce que j'appelais tout à l'heure de
mes voeux c'est une relance par
l'activité en sécurisant les petits
commerces c'est un changement complet du
paradigme ont-elles compte tel qu'on le
conçoit
emmanuel macron n'est que dans la
poursuite de ski ceux de ce qui se passe
depuis 20 ans et je pense que je pense
que d'autres solutions seraient seraient
apportés j'en ai parlé avec lui il
fallait un autre exemple parlant c'est
la difficulté qu'ont les commerçants à
pouvoir bénéficier d'un emprunt auprès
des banques parce que les banques ne
privée ne font pas leur métier de de
crédit et donc doter la banque publique
d'investissement d'une licence bancaire
c'est leur permettre d'accéder à des
crédits à taux zéro pour les voyez vous
avez accordé
sa philosophie générale commerçants
aussi par moments une part de
responsabilité sortons des
manifestations de nice trois minutes
d'émission
est-ce que par moments quand on voit par
le nombre de commerces fermés dans les
rues de dijon entre midi et deux
aujourd'hui zones commerciales
internationales est ce que vous vous
tirez pas une balle dans le pied aussi
parce que je veux qu'on l'a bien chargé
les manifestants dans cette émission
donc madame on attend dire est ce qu'on
peut se remettre en cause soi même par
moments bien entendu c'est comme alors
là je vais aller tout à fait dans ce
sens là effectivement je pense qu'il est
nécessaire d'ouvrir entre midi et deux
en centre ville de dijon parce qu'il a
travaillé
oui mais moi j'ai pas de pouvoir sur
commerçants mais dont ce que tu es oui
on discute c'est comme l'ouverture dès
dimanche effectivement la ville a
souhaité à ce que que nous soyons donc
en zone touristique
nous sommes sommes touristiques et les
graines sont ouvertes mais c'est tout
mais c'est tout mais patrick enders en
tout cas la ville de dijon prend ses
responsabilités pour avoir un centre
ville attractive et touristique avec
notamment la piétonnisation et puis
c'est d'actualité puisque dans quelques
jours nous allons avoir un magnifique
musée rénové qui va attirer du monde le
week-end des touristes mais aussi
beaucoup de dijonnais qui vont
redécouvrir des belles collections et un
beau centre ville ça veut dire que des
fois vous dites là les commerçants ils
pourraient faire un peu d'effort pour
justement essayer de remonter la pente
oui pas de honte à le dire j'ai été
adjointe au commerce de 2008 à 2014
c'est vrai qu'on avait travaillé sur sur
l'ouverture notamment sur la tranche
entre midi et deux on donne l'exemple à
la ville puisque on est en train aussi
nos services publics est bien de les
ouvrir de s'adapter au public et donc
j'espère certains beaucoup ont ils font
fait cet effort mais faut différents du
temps il faut changer les mentalités oui
il faut du temps pour jouer les
conventions des fois leur part de
responsabilité absolument donc il faudra
regarder ça de près il faut que tout ça
s'arrête finalement les manifestations
c'est ce que j'ai entendu des deux côtés
ça s'arrête et qu'axa cesse le samedi
c'est ce samedi alors et qu'ils arrêtent
de faire preuve d'égoïsme par rapport au
salaire quasiment très personnel
salariés et
vos commerçants merci à tous les trois
d'avoir participé à ce débat d'avoir
accepté de répondre à ces questions
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis dans
un instant un point sur l'actualité
régionale avec arnaud lefebvre suivi de
la partie nationale de dimanche en
politique francis letellier reçoit
yannick jadot tête de liste europe
écologie les verts aux européennes
je vous souhaite à tous et à toutes un
excellent dimanche sur france 3
[Musique]